lots of false information going
around notably on this issue of race
where it's the same old trick they use
against every republican they've used it
against donald trump
even though he's condemned white
supremacy a zillion times
including in the debate but then i guess
what he had some issue where he didn't
then totally condemn this one group that
we're being told as a white supremacist
group
joe biden's already got an attack ad out
about it are you willing
tonight to condemn white supremacists
and militia groups
and to say that they need to stand down
and not
add to the violence in a number of these
cities as we saw in kenosha
and as we've seen in portland are you
prepared to specifically
do it i would say almost everything i
see
is from the left wing not from the right
what are you what are you doing
what are you saying i'm willing to do
anything i want to see peace
sir say it do it say it you want to call
him
what do you want to call them give me
your name give me a white surprise
and write props stand back and stand by
[Applause]
the proud boys the white supremacists do
you know i mean the proud boys what
they're
they're the successor organization to
the ku klux klan right they're
a bunch of skinhead neo-nazi white
supremacists right
right that's what i've been told by the
mainstream media aren't they
it turns out they're not it turns out
they're not and you know how i figured
that out
a simple google search and then the
first article that comes up is usa today
so i click on usa today
they're left-wing but they're a little
more balanced obviously the new york
times or something like that
and i see right there at the top that
the proud boys have ties to white
supremacy okay well
all right they're white supremacists
that's it right but luckily i didn't
stop there luckily i read two paragraphs
down
where i found a fact that was very
confusing to me
apparently the leader of the proud boys
is a guy named enrique torrio
and enrique torrio is an afro-cuban
it's a black cuban and then
enrique torrio the afro-cuban leader of
the alleged white supremacist group
has has come out and said that there are
quote
long-standing regulations prohibiting
racist white supremacist
or violent activity
this according to the group's lawyer
ronald coleman he is also a spokesman it
turns out for the proud voice
now uh tario the leader the afro-cuban
leader says through coleman quote
we do not care what color you are or
what your background is if you love
america we consider you a brother
and then the group condemned racism
fascism communism
and socialism so okay we got
the white supremacist bad boys run by an
afro-cuban
condemning racism fascism communism and
socialism
then you've got the left then you've got
the left blm
in particular blm using explicitly
racist language
and forget condemning communism and
socialism openly embracing it
the leader of blm went on television
patrice colors and said we are trained
marxists
once again i should have known
the left is accusing the right of
the very thing that the left is doing
and the thing that the right is not
doing
look around the country at the
the destruction the violence the looting
the arson
the statues toppling down is that being
done by white supremacists i don't think
so
i don't see show me show me them i don't
see that i see antifa
no a lot of those guys are white but i
don't think they're white supremacists i
think they're anarchists and communists
i think they're leftists
a lot of it's being done by blm i don't
think those guys are white supremacists
all of that is being done with the
encouragement of elected democrats
it's just a lie it's just another lie
now i i had a hunch about this because i
remember i followed the proud boys a
little bit i don't really know the group
very well but i remember gavin mcginnis
founded it gavin mcginnis a comedian he
is a little edgy right he gets in
trouble i think i don't know i
only know him a little bit but i've
never known gavin to be a white
supremacist
and gavin's not running it anymore it's
this other fellow torio
and then i i thought because i've i've
seen it at different you know big
political rallies and there's a left
there and the right there
i have seen some proud boys and the
thing that's a little weird when you see
the proud boys
if you're told they're white
supremacists is you see a lot of black
proud boys and you see a lot of hispanic
proud boys
and then it turns out their leader is an
afro-cuban guy
just another lie i hope you enjoyed that
short segment from the michael knowles
show be sure to check out the full
episode linked in the description or
download the podcast wherever you listen
to podcasts
you